[Music]
hey guys in this video I'm bringing on
the fate of Arya Stark in fancies now
game drums supportive leagues and a few
theories and predictions of mine or evil
reunited Jon Snow in episode 1
she later in episode 3 fight alongside
Jon in epic battle for Winterfell
against the night king in his army Arya
will at some point be at King's Landing
and she will have a few encounters that
may not end well for some are able also
by my theory bed injury with all that
being said let's just jump in it
starting with a long anticipated reunion
between Arya and Jon as it has been
teased just to me Danny will arrive at
Winterfell in episode 1 season 8 in fact
their arrival is going to be an opening
scene of the final season there Jamil
arena to his friends and family most
importantly meet Arya Arya and Jon have
not seen each other since season 1 when
they had a pretty close sibling
relationship and they just missed each
other in season 7 which frustrated many
fans still sing Jon released one of his
sister's promising and if his reenacting
with sense that he'll also be seeing and
reuniting with Arya as well well it says
it'll say that John will be proud but
also blown away by how much Ari has
grown as a fighter it's also safe to say
that Arya unlike sense I will support
Jon decision of bending the knee to the
giant Queen in fact I think that Dany
Narnia will get along very well
considering how both of them admire in
respect strong and powerful women
also since arias passionate about her
gaming history and Dakin's dragon riding
Sister Wives says seen in season 2 it
was any Targaryen being her heroine we
can imagine she's predisposed to like
can be fascinated by Daniel dragons in
season 8 anyways beside reuniting me Jon
Snow I also expect Arya to reunite with
Nymeria as well at some point of the
final season most likely in episode 3
the two had a brief reunion in the
previous season when Aria was on her way
to Winterfell as re-approached I marry
Ananda leader the pack of wolves the
dire wolf she raised she told her she's
going home an answer to come with her
but the Amira refused and left along
with her pack or I realized this Nymeria
is no longer the same and has also
changed since the last time they saw
each other name area has a new life now
and is no longer attached to her anymore
however this cannot and most certainly
is not the last time we're going to see
in America
it's already been confirmed that we'll
see more of the dialogues in the final
season meaning not only of ghosts but
both of goals the Nymeria they're the
only dialogues whose stories are not
over yet and they'll definitely have a
role to play in the final six episodes
Nymeria might appear with a pack of
wolves in Episode three during the
battle for Vin FL and come to the Starks
Sango side or maybe two arias rescue
perhaps the best possible way for the
showrunners to get Amelia back in the
play would be with my marinating meat
Aria by saving her life this prediction
of mine simply result of considering
that John's Darville ghosts mostly
appeared in crucial moments such as
saving galore commoners life by biting
at the door and morning John that
there's something going on saving Sims
life from Wyatt and giving a chance to
join moment to destroy the white with
fire helping to kill wildlings during
the Battle of Castle black
protecting Sam and Gilly from two former
criminals in the Nights Watch that
attempted to hurt Gilly and also
defending John's corpse with all this
being said I think that arias durable
reappearance will be nothing less but
glorious Nymeria will appear and save
Arya as she did save her from Joffrey
but it's time she will save her from the
White Walkers saving her from Joffrey
cost in iberia to be forced to leave and
be separated from Arya but its timing
might cost me Mira's life
next I will also most likely have an
encounter with Melisandre fulfilling all
Santas prophecy that she told her I see
a darkness in you and in the darkness
eyes staring back at me brown eyes blue
eyes green eyes eyes that he'll shut
forever we'll meet again
Arya did shot all of these eyes the only
remaining thing of that prophecy to come
true is most Sanja meeting Ari again in
my opinion this Mel Sanchez prophecy
will definitely come true the question
is how is the meeting going to end well
Sandra is currently Melendez but as she
said it herself she'll return one last
time because she has to die in Westeros
we know Arya and we know that she's
dedicated to decreasing the names on a
kill list and we also know that
Melisandre is on the list because she
tried to kill ginjury if r is not
destined to put an end to Melisandre
then I can see the reunion taking place
in the first episodes of season 8 with
Arya eater killing Melisandre after
which Lord of Light will bring her back
to life since she has many things yet to
do as she set herself to John or
Melisandre could somehow managed to
convince Arya that she's saved John's
life which will bring her arias
absolution next and by far one of the
best Arya Stark predictions you'll have
a chance to hear include sir
death the gamble and reappearance of
jocking hogar season 7 finale providers
many Iranians but none of them was as
interesting as I reunion at the
carpeting click game writers a long
anticipated deal between the mountain
and the hound often referred to by fans
as cleganebowl has seemingly been set
for the final season in hysterically
game ball would take place a few moments
after death of Cersei Lannister upon
realizing that they invested in wrong
ruler as Cersei might cause the follow
Westeros since she is not supporting the
living side the Aran bank would hire the
faceless men to put an end to Cersei's
madness this is when Jackie would sneak
into Manor fell disguised as northerner
every night with aria
Jackie would then say to warrior that
the many-faced God requires another
death are you shocked and surprised but
most likely say that she is not no one
but rather Arya Stark of Winterfell
pointing out that she's not assassin and
does not plan to obey any order not to
kill anyone for the many-faced God Jack
Maldon revealed the name of a person
whose death is required the queen of the
Seven Kingdoms Cersei Lannister who
betrayed the living side and is
conquering the Seven Kingdoms for the
Great War ages are you already warning
to head to the capital and execute
Cersei Lannister in the very beginning
of season 7 which means that she will
most likely accept this offer in order
to not only cross the pass through the
biggest name on her list but also to
kill the only person who betrayed the
living side the hound who will in the
very first episode of the final season
arrive a meaningful with everyone else
will decide to help Aria
since with the mountain own array Ari
will not be able to either kill Cersei
or on the other hand survive upon
killing star say once they sneak into
the red keep the two would go straight
into Cersei chambers
our varying commerce face would likely
kill Cersei and just when the mountain
would joy sword to kill area for shadow
game ball will take place The Hound
would fulfill his promise that he gave
to the mountain in season 7 finale it's
not how it ends for your brother you
know who's coming for you evil is known
there's one leek in particular that goes
in favor to this theory which says that
our evil in episode 5 in King's Landing
and she will survive the burning of it
Arya Stark killest King's Landing Cersei
nothing can be said for sure there are
definitely some closer hints ok next is
my theory forest our story ending up
with her marriage to ginjury and living
out her days peacefully in storms end
ginjury the talented blacksmith and
bastard of King Robert Baratheon finally
reappeared in show and many fans have
you'd gimchi being back on the scene as
a sign that his father's promise to next
in season one might finally be fulfilled
remember back in the very first episode
in the Winterfell Crips Robert Baratheon
expressed his desire that his son should
marry that daughter to line their houses
forever Robert was talking about Joffrey
who he thought was his son and Ed's
daughter Sansa this never happened and
therefore House Stark and house
Baratheon have not been joined yet
however a huge amount of fans are
thinking that this marriage might
finally happen in the form of Roberts
only son ginjury and Ed's daughter Arya
our young Eng formed a special bond way
back when they were traveling together
north on Kings Road there's one
memorable scene that re-engages shared
that might have a shadow that those two
could become family one day when Genji
told Arya that he's never had a family
someone to take care of him Arya said I
could be your family
Ginji back then believe that human area
could never be together considering that
she's a highborn daughter of Lord Eddard
Stark while he on the other hand is just
a bastard son kinjal later found out who
is father Julius King Robert Baratheon
having in mind that tourism Winterfell
Val Genji on the other hand is heading
towards it with Jon Snow maintained a
Targaryen those two will most certainly
reunite in the very first episode of the
final season while many fans believe
re-engage we will end up together
many fans recommends that Arya would
never settle down and have children and
I understand him after all that sutorius
said herself regarding her future
however what we also need to understand
is that Game of Thrones is full of irony
Arya never wanted to be a lady or sister
saying Salvage dreamed of marrying a
handsome young man giving him children
and living a happy life wouldn't be kind
of Roenick singing aria a girl who never
won in any of that getting what sense
always wanted we all expect Arya to
either die in a battle or to live out
her days as an assassin adventurer and
that's why probably need her this will
happen it'll be too predictable
her getting a happy ending and living
her life as the proper lady she never
wanted to be able to be a huge twist for
a character Arya is a highly trained
assassin a thirst for vengeance
however at this point Ari already
avenged her family and when the war is
over and the White Walkers are dealt
with
I think the target will get alive that
sense is the dream of and ironically
Arya will enjoy the life so Aria will
most likely end up marrying injury and
leave other days raising their children
in a castle I have a son you have a
daughter will join our houses is the
code that's always been on my mind
obviously back then Robert was implying
than sense and Joffrey should bet but we
all know how it all worked out for them
however this in my opinion foreshadows
conjoined area during baratheon and
start houses once and for all some fans
even claimed that Georgia Marlins show a
nurse thought of re-injury while writing
this particular scene considering how
they tend to twist words around
aurilla does have feelings for Genji
which was made clear when she told him
that he can be her family also there
could be some clue regarding this
marriage in the first meeting between
Guidry and John it's quite obvious how
interaction between Guidry and John is
similar to one Robert and Ned had in
season one even that was reminds me of
Lordaeron taking injury and John under
his caring wing just like Lord the rain
did Robert and Ned also Robert was in LA
Fitness the Serleena just like injuries
with John's sister Arya so I'm sure you
can see the parallel now the tire has
finally returned to me nor Fallon Ginji
on the other hand has not only returned
to the series but is also heading to
Winterfell
it just seems they are meant to end up
together I can definitely see them
living their days out peacefully in
storms end with their children I'm sure
most of you are wondering how could they
live in a castle that belongs to house
Baratheon was surrounding injuries a
bastard son and therefore he's not
allowed to inherit his father's lands or
titles well there are two possibilities
one is a ginjury super son or Robert
Baratheon as there's a theory in which
his mother is actually Cersei Lannister
and the second possibility is him simply
getting legitimized by John or Dany
ginji's a bastard son of the late King
Robert Baratheon and with no living
Baratheon's left in the series he will
most likely get legitimized by Danny if
he agrees to bend the knee and swear his
loyalty to her which gain jury will most
likely do I understand that there are
some are you thinking that Dany
legitimizing injury would make no sense
some you think that she by doing that
she would be creating a potential rival
for the UH throne and even again she
personally is not a threat some of you
think you could either marry an
ambitious woman or have an ambitious
child well Dana statements say otherwise
Dany as well as John stated multiple
times throughout season seven the shell
should not be guilty for their father's
sins and doings
if the agnolotti Rhian to become her
most trusted advisor whose father did
more crimes to House Targaryen than
Robert did I don't see why Danny would
not legitimate injury if he will bend
the knee and sir his loyalty to her
enemies becoming Lord brothy on ginjury
would inherit storm's end and Arya will
most likely be his lady will Snell was
killed in season one which set of the
events for the series I cannot help but
think that needed fresh air this
marriage when he told Arya that she
marry a high Lord and rule his castle
just as Robert wanted back in the first
season the House Baratheon and Stark
will probably join through his son and
its daughter just not to the ones he and
Ned thought and as always I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace